so many great panels here at comic-con  so many people wait in line up to 24  hours to get into some of them however  what you may not know is there's a whole  series of panels with very short lines  yeah not a lot of interest in these  panels they're very easy to get into as  a public service to this year's Comic  Con attendees here are some panels this  weekend that have very very short lines  yeah there's putting the God in Godzilla  a faith-based discussion about Godzilla  as God's wrath yeah there's Chris splat  Chris Pratt drops various fruits from a  20-foot ladder  there's Peppa Pig secretly Jewish  there's picture ideas to DC were  Marvel's for zero compensation  there's Vin Diesel guest as your  preferred gender pronoun  the Vampire Diaries or True Blood cast  members of each show ask the audience  which one they were in and finally Black  Panther stories from the set as told by  white members of the movies  [Applause]